Das war's für heute.
Aus allen Ecken schreit das Scamas
Ich mein, was soll das für Blödsinn?
Das Wirr-Able, das ihnen den Rücken frei hält
Schlafen sie ein ohne Schäfchen zu...
Okay
Was?
Och Gott, das ist...
Das ist...
...Amazon Scamas
Du Doh
Einschlafhilfe
Schon mehr als 150.000
Nutzer schlafen schneller ein
Immer wenn sowas dahintersteht, bin ich ja skeptisch
Das wird nicht dampfen
Was, was, was?
Ein Licht-Metronom
What?
Egal, ich muss im Kreisel laufen jetzt
Kreisel-Quart...
Oh nee, ist die Map zugegangen?
Hm, hatten wir noch ne Map auf?
Nee, ich glaub wir hatten keine Map mehr auf
Okay, das war's
Machen wir mal ein bisschen was
Bisschen was...
Bisschen was Anspruchsvolleres
Easy
Da war ich noch ein bisschen zu frei
California
Oder auch nicht
Ach, jetzt
Oh Gott, ein Summoner-Bild
Ich bin kack noob, ich darf das
Ich hab fünf Jahre nicht gespielt
Und das ist meine erste League wieder
Und ich hab auch mit einem nicht Summoner-Bild
angefangen
Und hab festgestellt, dass
nicht Summoner-Bilds erstens
anstrengend sind, das wär nicht das Problem gewesen
Und zweitens viel mehr
Einsatz brauchen, sowohl was
Spielzeit angeht, was
Currency angeht, was alles angeht
Da hab ich mir gedacht, ich mach jetzt einfach Easy-Mode
und spiel Summoner-Bild
Was zum Einsteigen gut ist, finde ich
Oder kann ich allgemein auch nur
erzählen, weil das Spiel überfordert
einen total
wenn man neu ist
Ich hab den Vorteil gehabt, ich hab das vor fünf Jahren schon mal
relativ viel gespielt
Das heißt, die grundsätzlichen
Sachen kannte ich, aber
ich hab überhaupt keinen Plan, weil die ganzen neuen
Sachen, die sie eingeführt haben
Und ich checke die Hälfte der Gegenstände
immer noch nicht
Was es jetzt an Crafting-Materialien gibt
Alter, wie es ruckelt
Du bist auch ein Kampen
Du würdest es nicht spielen
Es hat jeder so seine
Prinzipien
Mich juckt das nicht
Aber ich hab in MMOs auch
immer keine Probleme gehabt, OP-Bilds
zu spielen
Außerdem ist das super
Wenn man
nebenbei spielen will
und Chat lesen mag
Erstmal ein Webinar
für POE belegen
Ist echt so
Also
Man müsste
mal einen von
den guten Content-Creator
und Streamer überlegen
Die sollen einen Udemy-Kurs machen
Die sollen Perso wechseln, Udemy-Kurs machen
Das würden sich garantiert Leute kaufen
Garantiert
Das Game ist so komplex
Mittlerweile, was es da alles gibt
Man kann einen Udemy-Kurs machen
Oh, was ist das da für ein Ding
Das ist irgendwas, was Damage macht
Was ist das
Der Mage
Hallo
Mops, Mops, Mops
Ihr schlagt auf den falschen
Ihr müsst auf den
Mops drauf
Easy, von wegen, der kann was
Easy, Summoner-Bild
Da kannst du nichts schiefgehen
Es ist wirklich
übelst kompliziert
Ok, jetzt ist nichts getroppt, was ich nicht kapier
Das hat zwar viel drauf, aber
Low-Rolls, das suckt
Übrigens, hier
Jetzt kann ich euch nochmal mein Pro-Tool anwerfen
Bäm, was könnte es wohl umgeverwehrt sein
Nix, nice
Das ist aber nicht wirklich akkurat
Sie sind fertig
Hier nochmal einen Ring aufheben
Und nochmal
den Metamorph bashen
Ich hoffe, der wird nicht zu OP jetzt
Oh, der hält ganz gut was aus
Hände hoch Leute, easy
Hände hoch
Oh fuck
Das ist so ein richtiges
Face-Roll-Bild
Richtig zum Face-Roll
Oh, da ist noch Zeug
Alter, jetzt, mein Rechner
Ich hab 5 FPS
Kann es mal sterben?
Alter, was ist da oben los?
Kann es mal sterben? Oh, jetzt ist
Am Start
Was ist jetzt los?
Meine OP-Monster sind nicht stark genug
Für Hast
Doch, jetzt
Jetzt easy mode
Was haben wir selbst gemacht
Nix
So muss das sein
Haben wir einen Getropped
Ein Herz, ein Riegel
Naja
Heldschirmgrenzen
Wir könnten mal gucken, ob wir vielleicht
Zutaten haben, uns einen Custom-Metamorph
zusammen zu basteln
Kannste ja auf Stadia spielen
Ohje, ich glaube, das wäre krass
Da würde ich ausflippen
Es ist zwar prinzipiell
ein Game, wo ich sagen würde, es eignet sich
für Stadia ganz gut, weil das ist kein Shooter
oder so
Aber
Ich glaube
Input-Lag ist hier übelst nervig
Ich glaube Input-Lag ist echt nervig
Wenn man das über Stadia spielt, gibt es wahrscheinlich
gar nicht auf Stadia
Ich mache mir jetzt in letzter Zeit immer mal einen Spaß
und suche mal nach Stadia
Stadia-Store
Können wir mal reingucken, ob was da
Was ist da
Games
So
Moment
Sie
Ist das immer noch alles ein Game-Auswahl?
Ernsthaft?
Es gibt, das ist doch bestimmt
Das glaube ich nicht, oder?
Das ist doch, das kann nicht alles sein
Ist das immer noch alles?
Das ist doch lächerlich
Alter, der
Den Scheiß stellen die morgen ein
Game
Blists
Nee, das ist alles
Super
Hot
Das ist wirklich alles
Alter, wer kauft sich das denn?
So was Sinnloses
So richtig
Typisches Google-Rohr-Krepierer-Produkt
wieder
Wer kauft sich den Kram denn?
What the fuck
Vor allem Baldur's Gate 3
Noch nicht mal ansatzweise raus
Mal gucken, wann das überhaupt rauskommt
Gibt es dazu schon Release Date?
Zumindest haben sie definitiv
Das sage ich ja auch nicht oft
Das richtige Studio dafür
Gewonnen für Baldur's Gate 3
Cyberpunk
Ist auch noch nicht raus, ja
Na gut, die müssen ja irgendwas darauf anzeigen
Ich meine, stellt euch mal vor, die machen Baldur's Gate 3 weg
Cyberpunk
Doom Eternal weg
Das ist ja ein Witz
Das meiste
Die Top-Games hier
Es sind von den ersten 8
Spielen
Die Top-Games
Da sind 3 Stück
Noch nicht erschienen
Das ist doch heftig, oder?
Google
Ich überlege mir die ganze Zeit, warum kann man sich nicht
Einfach den Store angucken
Die Sache ist die
Das ist alles, was im Store drin ist
Anscheinend
Was?
This year
Das erscheint mir aber ziemlich
Ok, wann
Soll das rauskommen?
Everywhere
To release
Was ist das für ein Satz?
Achso
Das würde mich auch überraschen
Wenn das noch 2020 kommt
Das ist der Witz
Stadia Shop
Haben die eine Shop-Uhr?
Nee, das ist die Games
Das ist die offizielle Stadia Games List
Wollen die uns
Eigentlich verarschen bei Google?
Ernst gemeinte Frage
Wollen die uns verarschen?
Ich meine
Die Leute, die sich eine Founders Edition gekauft haben
Ich habe die glücklicherweise noch abgestellt
Die kommen sich doch komplett verarscht vor
Geht
Geht eigentlich
Chrome mittlerweile
Play Stadia und Chrome
Anscheinend
Beinahe
Warum tun die so, als muss ich mir das kaufen?
Ich brauche doch einfach nur
Ich brauche doch einfach nur Chrome
Sign in, sign up
Geht das überhaupt
Im Chrome schon?
Also für mich ist das nicht ersichtlich
Ob das in Chrome funktioniert
Nee, für Updates
Wie spiele ich den Scheiß in Chrome?
Hier, sign in
Okay, ich gucke
Ich gucke
Das war's für heute.
Die angebliche Eresso Hubs und Moos.
Das war's für heute
Das war's für heute.
Das war's für heute, das war's für heute.
Ja, aber die Unix sind kacke, Unix sind in Path of Exile nix wert, ehm, Currency, Currency ist immer gut.
Ehm, Currency, Currency ist immer gut.
Reicht das jetzt? Ne, fünf Sachen braucht man, ne?
Okay, Unix, gut, easy.
Wo ist das? Da.
Du hast mich bei meinem Video gewinnspielt als Freunde. Ach, du meinst auf Twitch? Ne, auf Twitter voll, hab ich gelesen.
Hab ich gesehen.
Hab ich gesehen. So, äh, Moment.
Erstmal Zeug beschwören.
Hallo?
Oh, Crown Target, please.
Hallo, ich will den Affe targeten, nicht das Skelett.
Geht doch.
Auf geht's, ey.
Mashen, easy, der kann ja gar nix.
Ordentlich Drops.
Erstmal alles crammen, was irgendwie halt nicht sinnvoll aussieht.
Wieso gewinn ich dann auch was, weil du uns da eingetragen hast?
Oder ist es dieses komische Gewinnspiel, wo es darum ging, man muss einfach Leute erwähnen, die auch so hyped sind auf Google.
Ne, nicht auf Google, auf, ähm, Deforce und Gedöns.
Ah.
Das Loot ist zu viel.
Was haben wir hier? Das ist Crap.
Was haben wir hier? Das ist auch Crap.
Und legen noch paar Coins.
Was haben wir da?
Loot, Loot, Loot.
So, ich bin mal gespannt.
Ähm.
Das ist gar nicht so schlecht.
Ah, naja, das ist auch nix überragendes.
Das ist wahrscheinlich ziemlicher Crap.
Aber eins habe ich schon gecheckt.
Items mit diesen Support-Dingern drauf.
Also quasi, dass das irgendwelche Auren auslöst, Spells auslöst oder irgendwelche passiven Gems drin hat.
Die haben das Potential relativ viel wert zu sein.
Allerdings hat das Crap Rolls.
Äh, das ist Müll. Alles nix Gescheites.
Äh.
Alles.
Alles weg damit.
Oh, falsch.
Ich glaube, die habe ich nämlich noch nicht.
Doch, habe ich schon.
Was hat man eigentlich davon?
War eine Frage an die Kenner.
Bringt das überhaupt was, wenn man jeden einzelnen Node hier füllt?
Oder besser gesagt, muss man das vielleicht sogar machen?
Ich vermute mal, dass man das machen muss.
Aber so ganz sicher bin ich mir da nicht bei.
Oh ja, machen wir mal.
Iiih, eine Walden-Map.
Jetzt so Wolcen raus auf Papier.
Wolcen hat mich nicht angesprochen.
Vor allem durch die ganzen Bugs nicht.
Ah, der Boss ist gespornet.
Ich habe bei Dance Gaming ein bisschen geguckt.
Das erste Beispiel bei Wolcen.
Wolcen, wie spricht man das eigentlich genau aus?
Äh, gesehen habe ist, dass sie eben den Story-Progress gesettet haben.
Von Act 3 auf Act 2 zurück.
Durch den Bug.
Da habe ich mir gedacht, ach weißte was, warten wir das Ganze mal ab.
Zumal es mit Wolcen wohl Endgame-mäßig auch noch ziemlich dünn aussieht.
Und auch keine klare Strategie da ist.
Ich warte mal ab.
Wie gesagt, ich habe Pest of Exile am Anfang gespielt.
Zwischendurch ein bisschen.
Und jetzt nach 5 Jahren wieder.
Und da hat sich wenigstens ordentlich was getan.
Also bis die, bis Wolcen da in die Nähe kommt an Content finden,
noch eine ganze Weile dauern.
Zumal ja auch demnächst Pest of Exile 2 am Start ist.
In einem Jahr genau, genau.
So werde ich das machen.
In einem Jahr ist das erstens wahrscheinlich runtergesetzt.
Was mir persönlich eigentlich ziemlich wurscht ist.
Aber man sieht dann eben, ob das Spiel halt schon dead ist oder nicht.
Und angeblich muss es ja zumindest laut der GameStar,
den kann man zwar auch nicht immer alles glauben,
aber solche einfachen Sachen schon,
muss das ja wohl ein absolut katastrophaler Start gewesen sein bei Wolcen.
Also mit Online-Modus, die nicht funktionieren.
Krassen, also übertrieben krassen Progress Bugs.
Wo geht es denn hier rein?
Was ist das eigentlich? Chaos Orbs? Das kann man nie genug haben.
In einem Jahr ist es vielleicht mal fertig.
Man darf ja nicht vergessen, Wolcen war ja schon.
Wie jetzt eigentlich? Wolzen oder Wolzen?
Nicht, dass ich das hier immer doppelt aussprechen muss.
Life des Swift.
Das bringt ihm gegen Kreisspieler und Skeletter auch nichts, dass er Swift ist.
Wo ist mein Meta-Morph-Dude?
Guck mal her.
Wolcen also, okay.
Oder Wolcen?
Moment, warum stirbt er nicht?
Der lebt noch, der darf nicht.
Was ist denn das?
Das ist eine Sache, die habe ich halt in Path of Exile auch noch überhaupt nicht drauf,
zu erkennen, welche Unix was sind.
Man erkennt das ja an den Skins, obwohl man die, also bevor man die...
Okay, der Crap ist nix wert.
Der Crap ist nix wert.
Also erst mal hier die Trading-Seite aufmachen und gucken.
Aber wahrscheinlich ist der Crap überhaupt nix wert.
Nix.
Überhaupt nix wert.
Aber die meisten Unix sind in Path of Exile irgendwie nix wert.
Ich frage an die Kenner, welche Unix sind denn überhaupt was wert?
Gibt es überhaupt welche?
Also ich weiß, dass Dings hier Tabula Rasa ist was wert.
Weil halt Level-Item schlechthin.
Ansonsten, was gibt es für Unix, die ja was wert sind?
Die meisten Unix sind nix wert.
Ja gut, Headhunter ist das krasse Gegenbeispiel.
Headhunter ist halt auch ultra rare und mit das prognostere Item im Game.
Aber mal außer Headhunter, wo du ja quasi erstmal den Teufel beschwören musst, dass du überhaupt eine Chance hast, dass das droppt.
Und die Sterne in der richtigen Konstellation stehen müssen.
Aber was gibt es denn da sonst noch?
Weil den Crap kann man gleich verkaufen.
Oh nee, ich hab jetzt reingelaufen.
Unix-Items.
Stream lag auch nicht schon wieder.
Ok, Unity Media ist wieder, hat wieder zugeschlagen.
Leute, das liegt nicht an mir, das liegt dann, liegt offensichtlich an Unity Media.
Dann wird das heut mit Game Stream wohl eher nix.
Unity Media mag das nicht.
Dann machen wir jetzt was anderes.
Nachdem Unity Media keinen Bock hat heute, dass wir streamen können, wie man hier sieht.
Was hab ich jetzt gemacht?
Oh fuck.
Was hab ich denn jetzt getrieben hier?
Ich hab das irgendwie umgestellt und ich weiß nicht, wie ich das wieder zurückstelle.
Stell ich das wieder zurück?
Ist nicht schlimm, aber...
Unity Media gibt es eben vollkommen wurscht, mein Vertrag ist noch mit Unity Media.
Es ist jetzt Vodafone, aber egal ob Unity Media oder Vodafone, kriegt von mir wieder den Haufen.
Ich stell mal auf Just Chatting um.
Vielen Witz hier anscheinend, nix, danke.
Vodafone.
Schilsor Technik Talk ohne Path of Exile.
Weil ich hier gerne noch ein bisschen im Kreis kreiten würde.
Unix sind meistens einfach nur gute Leveling Items bis man genug gefarmt hat und bessere...
Es gibt ein paar Builds im Forum hab ich schon gesehen, die speziell Unix verwenden auch im Endgame.
Aber wirklich teuer ist davon eigentlich nix, was ja gut ist im Endeffekt.
So kann man sich das einfach kaufen, weil Farmen...
Wenn man schon ein Leak spielt mit dem wo man traden kann, da muss man sich in Kameras nicht erfarmen.
Äh, das spakt immer noch rum.
Hier unten, ich sehs ja, es spakt immer noch rum.
Also wenn das nicht besser wird bei Unity Media bzw. Vodafone, dann müssen wir mal wieder...
Übels flamen auf Twitter.
Denkt daran, Unity Media ist jetzt Vodafone.
Wie kommt mit uns in die Service Zukunft?
Leute, so sieht die Service Zukunft aus.
Also man hat sich gefragt, wie sieht die Service Zukunft aus?
Frame Drops.
IQ, Unity Media. Perfekt.
Leute, ich kann mich nicht zurückhalten.
Anzeige jetzt raus, ich weiß, direkt kommen die Feministen an.
Ich war einfach dazu gepasst irgendwie.
Ok, gucken wir uns mal Vodafone Services an.
Auf dem großen Unpacked Event, das geht mir nicht auf den Sack, ich will einfach noch zerscheißen, funktioniert.
Ich brauch noch nicht mal hier dieses krasse Multitasking, wie der Opa auf der Seite.
Ich brauch kein Handy, kein Telefon, keine Fernbedienung mit Fernseher, kein Notebook auf dem Schoß.
Ich brauch einfach einen funktionierenden Upload, den ich ja auch noch...
Ich bezahle, die haben mich ja halb skamast bei Unity Media.
Ich bezahle ja meinen Upload doppelt.
Ich bezahle Power Upload und ich bezahle Power Upload.
Ich bezahle zweimal Power Upload.
Ich bezahle einmal Power Upload für Power Upload zu haben
und bezahle nochmal Power Upload für richtiges, echtes Dualstack zu haben.
Also richtig, richtig huge skamas.
Ach man, äh...
Läuft's jetzt eigentlich? Nee.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Ich flamen die jetzt.
Ich flamen die jetzt auf Twitter.
Und zwar...
Wen sollen wir flamen? Wollen wir Vodafone Service flamen?
Oder noch Unity Media Hilfe?
Unity Media hat... Ich schreib einfach beide an, ja klar.
Unity Media hat den Vorteil, dass die meine Daten haben
und ich sie nicht wieder posten muss.
Warum krieg ich eigentlich so viele Twitter-Posts von Montana Black Amp wohl?
Ich folge ihm nicht.
Ich hab eigentlich mit ihm überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Okay, also wir schreiben jetzt gleich das Add.
Wie heißen die? Unity Media Hilfe.
Und Add. Wie heißen die anderen? Vodafone Hilfe.
Ups.
Ich hab aus Versehen abgeschickt, lol.
Ich hab mir eine leere Nachricht abgeschickt.
Wie heißt die? Vodafone Service.
Okay, also. Was schreiben wir jetzt?
Frametrops. Ich kann ja nicht Frametrops schreiben.
Da sitzt der Service-Mensch davor und überlegt sich erstmal.
Von was redet er denn? Hat er schon mal seinen Router neu gestartet vielleicht?
Weil wir wissen ja bekannlicherweise, beim Support ist Router neu starten das Mittel der Wahl.
Ohne Router neu starten tut sich ja da nichts.
Router muss neu gestartet werden.
Okay, wir schreiben jetzt genau. Wir schreiben jetzt nichts.
Zeit heute Abend. Abend.
Kein Stream möglich.
Kackt alle 5 Min ab und die Bandbreite bricht ein.
So.
Bam.
Abgeschickt. Mal gucken.
Mal gucken ob da noch einer arbeitet bei denen.
Ich glaube ja nicht so spät. Ich erwarte das auch gar nicht.
Mal gucken. Mal gucken ob da jetzt noch eine Antwort drauf kommt.
Ich hoffe die schreiben nicht public irgendwie meine Kundennummer oder sowas.
Aber sowas sind sie eigentlich immer vorsichtig.
Hatte ich bisher nie Probleme.
Man muss auch sagen der Twitter-Support gibt sich immer viel Müll.
Die können auch letztendlich nichts machen.
Verlorene Pakete. Tja.
So genau habe ich das alles nicht analysiert.
Ich weiß nur.
Also ja natürlich. Unter dem Strich schon.
Ich weiß nur das definitiv irgendwas nicht stimmt.
Und das liegt nicht an Unity Media. Das liegt nicht an Twitch.
Das liegt nicht an mir. Sondern das liegt auf dem Weg dahin bei Unity Media.
Wo davon ist das neue Hermes was Paketverlust angeht?
Ich hatte mit Hermes noch nie Paketverlust.
Hattest du mit Hermes schon mal Paketverlust?
Der Sebaro. Wo ist der Sebaro eigentlich?
Wo ist der Sebaro?
Ich habe ja gar keine Ahnung.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Aber ich kann das sagen.
Ich kann das sagen.
Das war's für heute.
Gigabit Cable.
Tarife.
Schauen wir mal.
Cable Max, das ist doch was für mich.
Und Max, was hast du für Inhalt?
Natürlich Cable Max.
Ich glaube, ich sollte ihn mal vorschlagen.
Wir sollten uns zusammen tun.
Das passt einfach zu gut.
Ich muss mal Cable Max sponsoren.
Und dann erzähle ich einem Streamer auch immer, wie gut Unity Media Cable Max ist.
Post die Telekom aber nicht wie verrückt Super Vectoring.
Ja doch, weil die Telekom noch auf Teufel kommen raus, ihren alten Kupferkram halt an den Mann bringen will.
Die haben ja auch keine Wahl.
Sollte es auch machen.
Irgendetwas kostet das jetzt?
Oder wo sieht man jetzt, was es ist?
Was? Alter, was ist mit euch los?
Seht ihr das hier? Moment.
Hier.
Was ist denn das für ein beknacktes Verhältnis?
1000 m down, 50 ab.
Ernsthaft?
Was haben die alle gesoffen eigentlich?
Wollen wir mit dem Experte sprechen?
Was könnten wir den Experten denn fragen?
Ach nee, das geht gar nicht.
Das ist ja doof.
Ich dachte da kommt jetzt so ein Chatbot oder sowas.
Eigentlich wollte ich den Experten erstmal fragen, geh weg, warum kann man nicht einfach auf die Seite klicken, ohne dass was passiert?
Wollte den Experten fragen, was mache ich, wenn ich mehr Upload haben will?
Dann wollte ich den Experten fragen, ob er mir erklären kann, was doofes der Kleid ist.
Ich mein, okay, 50 MBit, wenn man mal ehrlich ist, sind 50 MBit wirklich gut.
Aber das Verhältnis von 1000 zu 50 ist halt schon der Witz.
Das reicht ja gerade mal aus, dass wenn du TCP-Bestätigungspakete verschickst, dass quasi für vollen Download die Bestätigungspakete verschickt werden können.
So über Daumen gepeilt.
Ja, ich will mit dem Experten sprechen, aber geht ja nicht.
Siehst du uns schon?
Ich sehe meinen Berater im Browser.
Oh Gott, ich will gar nicht so viel zwischenmenschliche Interaktion.
So ein Chatfenster wird mir voll und ganz reichen.
Live-Chat?
Nee, wo?
Wo habe ich Live-Chat?
Ich sehe keinen Live-Chat.
Nur bis 20 Uhr, wir haben 21.30 Uhr keinen Live-Chat.
Da gibt es den Live-Chat, was?
Ihr seht mehr als ich.
Wo davon hat geantwortet?
Sende mir mal bitte deine Handynummer per DM.
Meine Handynummer?
Warum zum Geier braucht er meine Handynummer?
Ich sehe gerade, dass die Werte echt nur semigut sind.
Sende mir mal bitte deine Handynummer.
Okay.
Wo habe ich mein Handy?
Warte mal, ich hole kurz mein Handy.
Okay.
Jetzt leaken.
Nein, nicht leaken.
Für irgendwas muss ich lohnen, dass ich einen zweiten Monitor habe, oder?
Was bedeutet eigentlich, die Werte sind semigut?
Schicke ich ihm das mal.
Eine Sache, die mich am iPhone immer verwirrt ist.
Wie findet man im iPhone seine eigene Nummer?
Als ernst gemeinte Frage.
Gibt es einen Trick, wie man im iPhone seine eigene Nummer gut und einfach findet?
Kontakte.
Ja, Kontakte bin ich.
Und dann?
Oben?
My Card steht da.
My Card.
Chat?
Huge.
Oh, Christine antwortet uns.
Dann ist alles gut.
Ich bin Fan von Christine.
Dann sind wir in guten Händen.
Was weiß ich, wie Christine ausschaut?
Keine Ahnung.
Christine klingt kompetent.
Okay.
PN?
Based.
Handy nur.
Gut, ist raus.
Handy Nummer ist raus.
Komm, Christine kriegt jetzt auch den passenden Emoji als Antwort.
Weil wir uns ja freuen, dass sich jemand drum kümmert.
Was?
Ich kann keine Emojis kopieren.
Warum nicht?
Das geht nicht.
Das ist nicht legal.
Die Maschine.
Alter, der Twitch-Chat wieder.
Der Chat.
Christine guckt bestimmt gerade in Stream.
Wenn das so wäre, wäre das witzig.
Moin, Christine.
Falls du zuguckst.
Ich glaube es ja eher nicht.
So Leute, wir warten jetzt mal, bis sie sich rühren bei Unity Media bzw. Vodafone.
Ich muss mich da immer noch dran gewöhnen.
Wisst ihr, was bei uns in Frank...
Ich frage mich gerade, was die machen.
Google Maps Frankfurt.
Weil bei uns ist es so, dass Vodafone und Unity Media direkt gegenüber einen Shop haben.
Nicht Willy Brandt Platz.
Schweizer Platz.
Die müssten doch dann dicht machen.
Hier ist nämlich...
Wo macht man die Satelliten-Ansicht?
Hier oben ist nämlich...
Wo geht es zum Südbahnhof?
Hier oben ist nämlich direkt gegenüber...
Unity Media Store.
Und hier ist irgendwo...
Vodafone.
Ach, Moment.
Telekom Store?
Ich glaube ich verwechsel das jetzt.
Das ist ein Unity Media und ein Telekom Store.
Ah, okay, dann passt das.
Älter Steine. Ja, den habe ich letztens sogar gesehen.
Hier, irgendwo.
Südbahnhof.
Ich laufe hier lang.
Hier irgendwo.
Irgendwo hier auf der Ecke habe ich ihn letztens gesehen.
Wo ist denn hier?
Frankfurt Vodafone Shop.
Ach, da oben.
Ist hier nicht irgendwo auch der Apple Store?
Der Apple Store ist doch hier auch so.
Da oben irgendwo.
Ah, genau, da ist nämlich auch...
Nee, das ist...
Ich kann mich immer bei Frankfurt in der Vogelperspektive überhaupt nicht orientieren.
Ich dachte aber irgendwo bei der Goethe-Straße.
Goethe-Straße.
Louis Vitor Store.
Zahl die Kollektion bar.
Pick auf Sponsor.
Einzigen Haftbefehl Lyrics, die ich kenne.
Und nicht mal weil sie gut sind.
Einfach nur weil es in Frankfurt und die Straße geht, wo ich quasi jeden Tag durchlaufe.
Gut.
Tja Leute, warten wir mal ab, was Unity Media so treibt.
Tue nicht so, als wären das die einzigen.
Doch, sind die einzigen.
Was kann ich denn sonst noch?
Ich kann nichts.
Kann ich nichts.
Übrigens, ich hatte letztens...
Das muss ich jetzt mal erzählen.
Es kann sein, es kann sein, dass wir letztens mit Haftbefehl zusammen mexikanisch essen waren.
So bescheuer das jetzt klingt.
Also ich meine, ich wusste nicht, dass das Haftbefehl ist.
Weil... Wo habe ich die Musik?
Machen wir noch mal an.
Wir sind hier letztens futtern gegangen.
Und zwar mexikanisch.
So, hier sind wir letztens Mittagessen gegangen.
Und zwar...
Da.
Und als wir reingekommen sind, waren die Verkäuferinnen überhaupt nicht ansprechbar.
Und ich habe dann irgendwann mitgekriegt, dass die eine mit irgendeinem Typ, was durchaus hätte Haftbefehl sein können, keine Ahnung, ich habe mir den nicht anguckt, Selfies gemacht hat.
So. Und als wir dann durchgelaufen sind, haben die sich auch irgendwas von Haftbefehl und Haftiabi erzählt, die Verkäuferinnen.
Und ich habe sie dann gefragt, wer war denn der... Kennt man den?
Und die meinte, das war ein Deutschrapper.
War eher drei Meter groß. Der war eigentlich ziemlich normal groß.
Sind die Toiletten immer noch im Keller? Ich war ja noch nie auf dem Klo da.
Die Ahabie.
Also es kann durchaus sein, dass ich sogar unbewusst mit Haftbefehl mexikanisch essen war.
Also eigentlich ist mein Leben jetzt vorbei.
Jetzt ist es durch.
Ich habe sie leider nicht gefragt, wer das genau war. Sie hat halt bloß gesagt, das war ein Deutschrapper.
Und dann meinte ich, also gut, kann ich nicht mitreden.
Vielleicht war es doch irgendein anderer Typ, keine Ahnung.
Nicht, dass es jetzt einen großen Unterschied machen würde.
Gerüchte zur Folge ist Haftbefehl 3,29 Meter groß.
Natürlich. Und Montana Black ist wie alt? 24 oder so?
Ich kenne mich leider bei den Montana Black Memes nicht so richtig aus.
Aber da gibt es doch irgendwie so ein Standardalter, was er ist.
Das kenne ich mich nicht aus.
Oder war das Kronk, der 24 ist?
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Geht alles an mir vorbei.
Letztens habe ich wieder...
Nee, Kronk ist 12, genau.
Letztens habe ich ja mal wieder die absolut geballte Intelligenz auf Twitter gesehen.
Ich weiß, dass Kronk natürlich älter ist.
Ich weiß nicht, dass Kronk nicht Gregor Onk heißt.
Was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Genau, ich habe letztens mal wieder einen Tweet empfohlen bekommen von Montana Black.
Da hat er sich irgendwie über...
Da hat er irgendeine retweetet, die angeblich...
Das ist so...
Allein, was ein Bullshit, mit was die Leute sich befassen, ist schon der Wahnsinn.
Natürlich könnte man sich jetzt darüber lustig machen, dass ich mich darüber...
Nein, nein, der ist nicht 95.
Stimmt, mit 95, das meinte ich, genau.
95, Geburtsjahr, das ist der Gag immer gewesen.
Ich weiß, der ist nicht so viel jünger als ich.
Wir sind da nicht...
Wir sind altersmäßig nicht so weit auseinander.
Da hat er irgendwie eine retweetet.
Da war die gesamte geballte Intelligenz...
Ich zeige euch mal den Tweet.
Da war die geballte Intelligenz von Auftwitter wieder am Start.
Da hat er eine retweetet, die...
Oh, nee.
Der Tweet ist weg.
Aber zumindest, Leute, wer mal wirklich die komplette geistige Unterschicht versammelt sehen will,
der liest sich die Antworten durch.
Mir geht es gar nicht so sehr um den Tweet an sich, sondern um die Antworten.
Alter, meine Güte, ey, die Leute.
Er hat irgendwie eine retweetet, die angeblich von Jesus in Hamburg,
nachdem sie ihn nach einem Selfie gefragt hat, weggeschubst wurde.
Wo ich mir gedacht habe, warum lese ich so eine Scheiße überhaupt?
Es geht mir eigentlich total am Arsch vorbei.
Aber ich kann manchmal nicht aufhören, entgegen besseren Wissens
mir dumme Kommentare auf Twitter durchzulesen und danach wieder an der Welt zu verzweifeln
und mich zu wundern.
Wie dämlich kann man im Kopf eigentlich sein?
Genau, von Jesus.
Wie spricht man den Typ eigentlich aus?
Gitzitz.
Diese ganze Deutschrap-Geschichte ist so ein Abfuck.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man sich das geben kann.
Ja, genau, Halfcore, genau, genau, genau.
Die Nachricht von dem Vodafone-Helfer ist ja voll korrekt.
Ja, was, das ist doch gut.
Dafür ist er ja da.
Oder sie, es ist ja.
Der Christin.
Frauenkontakt, Leute.
Hoi, hoi, hoi.
Jetzt wird es aber kritisch langsam.
Guck mal, die Antworten.
Na gut, manchmal hat es einen Vorteil, wenn man ein paar Follower auf Twitter hat.
Jesus spricht man, sagt, was kann.
Meinetwegen.
Wie gesagt, ich habe es ja schon ein paar Mal gesagt.
Es gibt nur eine Sache, wo ich mich bei Deutschrap mit identifizieren kann.
Und das hat mit Deutschrap nichts zu tun.
Das liegt einfach an meinem Alter.
Genau, KioKon weiß das noch.
Um was es ging.
So, machen wir eigentlich im Stream was außer auf Unity Media zu warten?
Gerade nicht wirklich, oder?
Die sind immer so glücklich, die Leute, wenn sie den Kram verwenden.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Die sind immer so happy.
Ist es wenigstens, das ist kein MacBook, Leute.
Kein MacBook.
Das ist aber nicht hipster genug.
Also wenn der richtig cool wäre, hätte er dann MacBook gehabt.
Ja, können wir machen.
Das ist eine gute Zeitüberbrückung.
Moment, ich habe meinen Mauskabel irgendwie unter dem Mauspad eingeklemmt.
Wie kriegt man das hin?
Das ist so ein Trick, wenn man den reproduzierbar hinkriegt.
Wenn man den reproduzierbar hinkriegen würde, könnte man damit fast auftreten.
Wie habe ich das Kabel jetzt unter das Mauspad gekriegt, ohne das Mauspad anzuheben?
Nee, ist immer noch drunter.
Ich glaube auch nicht, dass die Support Leute glücklich sind bei Unity Media.
Generell glaube ich nicht, dass Support Leute glücklich sind.
Das ist ja auch der Grund, warum ich nie im Leben im Support arbeiten möchte.
Ich habe letztens wieder was gepostet, was ich mitgekriegt habe beim Support.
Hat einer angerufen, höchste Priorität, unser Abrechnungssystem geht nicht mehr.
Dann haben die Leute vom Support gefragt, wer sind sie überhaupt und um was für ein System geht es.
Und dann kam die super erhellende Antwort, es geht um das System, was PDFs generiert.
Ah, yes, excellent information, jetzt weiß man sofort Bescheid.
Alles klar, sofort, entstört, noch während der Anruf.
Das ist der Grund, warum ich nicht im Support arbeiten will.
Ich setze mich nicht gerne mit Leuten auseinander.
Und das ist im Support her taktiklich der Fall.
Stream ist jetzt komplett dead.
Was macht Unity Media?
Es geht wieder.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, yeah.
Unity Media, come on, brah.
Äh, ne, nicht brah, es ist ja Christine.
Christine, Christine misst gerade irgendwas.
Stream läuft noch ohne Probleme, hast du aber Glück, dass es bei dir ohne Probleme klappt.
Im Support bekommt man die ganze Laune um menschliche Dummheit.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ich kann mir auch vorstellen, Christine hat was Besseres zu tun,
eigentlich als um mit irgendeinem Spack von YouTube,
beziehungsweise von Twitch, da, also quasi mit mir,
um 21.45 Uhr auf Twitter Support zu schreiben.
Die hat da eigentlich gar keinen Bock drauf.
Kann ich verstehen, hätte ich auch nicht.
Ich versuche immer nett zu den Support Leuten zu sein,
weil ich kann mich da gut reinversetzen, dass es halt suckt.
So ein Alex.
Du meinst so den richtigen Jesus.
Wie spricht man den Kerl eigentlich richtig aus?
Jesus.
Style.
Ja, das habe ich nämlich gar nicht dazu erzählt.
Also, wo es ja um diese Selfie ging, diese Twitter-Meldung, die ich da gesehen habe,
da muss er wohl geantwortet haben, so nach dem Motto,
Selfie gibt es nur gegen Dreier mit deiner Freundin.
Und dann hat sich halt das Mädel ertreistet zu sagen, nein, will sie nicht.
Und dann hat Jesus sie angeblich weggeschubst,
sodass sie zwei Meter rückwärts getan hat.
Sodass sie zwei Meter rückwärts getaumelt ist.
Es ist aus allen Bereichen sehr theatralisch berichtet.
Zwei Meter ist eine ganz schöne Entfernung.
Zutrauen.
Tue ich das zu den Leuten aber ohne Probleme.
Okay, gucken wir mal ein bisschen Programmer-Humor.
First Level Support ist halt Idiotenfilter, ist tatsächlich so.
Der Typ ist der mega Asiorg.
Die ganzen Deutschrap-Typen, ich kann mir das überhaupt nicht geben.
Echt nicht.
Da verlierst du jegliche Gehirnzellen danach.
Sowohl von den Leuten an sich.
Ich sag ja immer, es ist nicht notwendig, wenn einem die Musik gefällt,
dass man quasi den Leuten dahinter irgendwie folgt oder das weiter.
Also ich kann durchaus sagen, ich mag die Red Hot Chili Peppers,
ich hab keine Ahnung, was sie in den letzten 30 Jahren getrieben haben.
Juckt mich nicht, ist mir auch wursch.
Aber die Deutschrap-Typen, die drängen sich ja quasi direkt in die Öffentlichkeit.
Wer war das mit der Polizei, der sich dann entschuldigt hat danach
und übelst den Schwanz eingezogen hat?
Wer war das? War doch auch letztens irgendwas.
Du scheiß Fanboy.
Was war denn das überhaupt wieder für einer?
War er das nicht auch?
Nee, das war ein anderer.
Flair, Flair war das, genau.
Es gibt immer noch gute, die sind in den Hintergrund gerutscht.
Ja, leider.
Es ist aber immer so, dass Mainstream ist halt der Bodensatz in der Regel.
In der Regel ist Mainstream halt der absolute Shit.
Sowohl von der musikalischen Qualität her als auch irgendwie von den Leuten.
Es ist einfach nur Bullshit.
Deswegen, das einzig wahre, höre ich zum größten Teil eigentlich nur Hard Rock und Heavy Metal.
Beste.
Ich mein, da gibt es Leute wie Ozzy, die sich noch mit einer Gehhilfe live auf die Bühne stellen.
Und irgendwie noch einen Ton rauskriegen.
Ist nicht so wirklich meine Musik, aber muss man Respekt für haben.
Es gibt bestimmt normale Leute, auch bei Deutschrapern, keine Frage.
Natürlich.
Ich bin halt wie immer die 10, 15 Oberspasten, die es halt für alle anderen versauen.
Eminem, Eminem kann ich mir auch gut anhören.
Ohne Scheiß.
Letztens irgendwie 20 Jahre oder so gefühlt nichts mal mitgekriegt von dem Kerl.
Neues Album am Start.
Was mir gar nicht schlecht gefallen hat, obwohl ich kein großer Hip Hop Fan bin.
Wen ich auch ganz gerne gehört hab, Hip Hop mäßig, ist der Linkin Park MC, wie es so schön heißt.
Als der noch Sachen abseits von Linkin Park gemacht hat.
Das fand ich auch immer ganz nett.
Aber ich bin kein großer Hip Hop Fan.
Ist halt einfach nicht meins.
Aber man muss anerkennen, es gibt auch da ein paar gescheite Sachen.
Gucken wir uns mal ein bisschen Programmer Humor an, bis das Team sich das angenommen hat.
Oh, ich hab ne Nachricht gekriegt von Vodafone.
Lieber Kunde, Unity Media ist jetzt Vodafone. Willkommen bei uns.
Perfekt.
Bester Willkommensgruß. Erstmal Stream abkacken.
Huge, by the way, immer noch.
Wir haben hier Anliegen aufgenommen und melden uns schnellstmöglich bei Ihnen.
Okay, das ist ja ne langweilige Message.
Die Technik ist informiert.
Das erinnert mich an.
Ich habe die Technik gerade informiert.
Du wirst per SMS auf dem Laufenden gehalten.
Liebste Grüße, Christine.
Ich fang gleich an zu schwitzen, Leute.
Oh nein, sorry, da Vodafone support.
Warum sieht's denn die? Weil das wahrscheinlich Policy ist bei denen.
Techniker ist informiert, das erinnert mich auch an.
Aber es hat das letzte Mal auch funktioniert.
Techniker ist informiert.
Genau, feels wow, man. Vodafone, Christine.
Ich finde es top, dass die um so... Das schreiben wir da jetzt. Wir sind mal nett.
Wir sind mal nett.
Ich schreib Ihnen mal zurück.
Schön, dass ihr euch auch um solche Uhrzeit noch um Probleme kümmert.
Um Probleme kümmert.
Schleimer.
Soll ich den Jesus-Style machen?
Soll ich sagen, Dreier mit deiner Freundin?
Oder kein Tweet?
Nein, wir sind nett.
Ich lasse Sie sich darum kümmern.
Gut, es ist fast 22 Uhr, wir haben mit diesem Stream fast nichts gemacht, weil es halt rumspackt.
Techniker sind informiert.
Hallo Christine, schön, dass ihr euch um diese Uhrzeit noch um Probleme kümmert.
Support-Mitarbeiter freuen sich auch, wenn die Leute sich freuen und sie nicht immer angeschissen werden.
Kann ich euch aus eigener Erfahrung sagen, ich bin zwar nicht im Support, aber ich sitze nicht weit davon entfernt.
Was haben wir hier? Gibt es wenigstens noch ein paar Lulz, bevor wir ins Bett gehen können?
Sie hat jetzt seine Nummer, dann kann sie dir auch ihre geben.
Ist klar.
Der Twitch Chat Dating-Tipps.
Da bist du verlassen, wenn du dich auf den Twitch Chat verlässt.
Gibt es eigentlich irgendwas, warum man sich auf den Twitch Chat verlassen kann?
Was hältst du von Shelly Cloud?
Top, perfekt.
Das beste in dieser Kategorie.
Kannste dir kaufen, habe ich auch 15 Stück, aber nicht alle eingebaut.
Das habe ich ja schon öfters gezeigt, die Dinger habe ich als Relay für meine Lichtschalter.
Ich habe letztens einen ganz merkwürdigen Channel auf YouTube gefunden.
Das muss ich euch jetzt mal zeigen, wo es um das Thema Heimautomatisierung ging.
Man sieht genau, wie der Channel hieß.
Das war ein Channel, die haben sich legit mit dem Thema Heimautomatisierung beschäftigt.
Aber es waren sehr leicht begleitete Mädels, die das Thema besprochen haben.
Ich hatte überrascht, dass die Kombination aus seriösem Inhalt und halbnackter Mädels gerade im Heimautomatisierungsbereich auf YouTube zusammenfindet.
Wie hieß das denn?
Man findet es bestimmt relativ schnell, weil es viel...
Ja, hier.
What the fuck?
Okay, hier haben sie ja noch...
Also das Video, das ich gesehen habe, hatte so weniger an.
Dieses Thema in Kombination hätte ich jetzt nicht mit gerechnet.
Weil jemand gefragt hat, was das ist, das ist ein Relay zwischen Lichtschalter und Lampenfassung schalten bzw. eigentlich umgedreht.
Du schaltest mit dem alten Lichtschalter nur noch das Relay über den...
Also schaltest mit dem Schalter quasi einen Schalter.
Und das ist halt richtig gut, weil es ist klein.
Es passt unterputz in die Dose.
Also das heißt, man kriegt das hin.
Das ist auch der Wife-Acceptance-Faktor ist hoch, weil man sieht halt nichts, was hier für viele auch nicht unwichtig ist.
Die Firmware, mit dem das ausgeliefert wird, ist auch komplett offline-fähig.
Ich habe schon 50 Mal im Stream gesagt, die Bezeichnung dieser Produkte und die...
Die Url, die Domain ist komplett bescheuert.
Das große Herausstellungsmerkmal bei den Shelley-Geräten ist, dass sie offline funktionieren.
Und was machen sie?
Eine Domain, die alles andere aussieht als offline.
Woran denkt ihr bei Shelley.cloud?
Ihr denkt doch bestimmt, wenn ihr Shelley.cloud lest als erstes, das ist bestimmt ein Produkt, was sich super offline verwenden lässt, oder?
Ich weiß nicht, was sich da die Marketing-Pros bei Shelley so überlegt haben.
Aber eines der herausragenden Merkmale von den Shelley-Sachen ist, dass sie erstens eine Open Source-Firmware drauf haben,
die alles kann, was man so braucht und halt offline funktioniert.
Und nur optional irgendwelche Cloud-Geschichten kann, also warum es Shelley.cloud ist.
Nee.
Nein, ist es nicht, Halbkorn.
Das sind Relays zum Strom.
Unterputz-Strom-Schalt-Gramm.
Naomi, wo die kenne ich auch.
Für 3D-Trocker-Gramm.
Ja, die gibt es auch.
Es gibt viele Channels, Technik-Channels mittlerweile.
Was ich auch letztens gefunden habe, ist, ich stoße da jetzt.
Und bevor jetzt der erste wieder anfängt, ja ja, Max, hast du es gefunden, ja.
Doch, ich stoße tatsächlich immer zufällig auf solche merkwürdigen YouTube-Channels.
Auch oftmals in der, oder was heißt merkwürdig?
Channels, die erstmal merkwürdig anmuten, ja.
Spezialist vs. Gamer.
Ja, ist klar.
Der Spezialist mit dem Controller in Call of Duty auch so wahnsinnig onen wird.
Ähm, denk ich es dir, letztens habe ich ein tasty PC.
Was, what the fuck, geh da wieder ab.
Die flüstert dann auch noch, die flüstert quasi so ASMR-Style.
Dann irgendwann die Grafikkarten-Specs und sowas ins Mikrofon.
Was es sich alles gibt mittlerweile auf YouTube.
Und ich stolper wirklich immer zufällig über solchen Content.
Chelly.local war schon für das lokale Netz reserviert.
Ja,.local ist glaube ich auch keine gültige Top-Level-Domain.
Wobei mittlerweile ja fast alles irgendwie möglich ist in der Top-Level-Domain.
Dort, wo ich arbeite, wir haben eine eigene Top-Level-Domain.
Ich weiß nicht, wen wir dafür bestochen haben.
Wir haben eine eigene Top-Level-Domain.
Okay, mal gucken, ob wir noch was zu lachen finden hier, bevor wir ins Bett müssen.
Oder was ich gesagt habe, wir.
Also eine Sache, die ich garantiert nie machen werde, ist den Twitch-Chat mit ins Bett nehmen.
Egal wie cute der Chat heute ist.
Mal gucken, hat Christine nochmal geantwortet.
Ne, wusste ich auch nicht.